your girlfriend Vanessa Hudgens is
engaged I gotta ask you though as her
bestie like are the bachelorette party
plans in like happening what can we
expect you guys got to do it big well I
mean I know she moved heaven on Earth to
be able to make it to my bachelorette so
I will be doing the same for when she
ever whenever she has hers we are both
very busy women so she hit you up for
any advice as far as wedding planning
goes oh she didn't even have to hit me
up I went over
I legitimately brought books over I
legit so when she came back from Paris I
surprised her at her house like another
friend of ours and like we had balloons
and like we surprised her with like
champagne and balloons and like I
brought over all of my wedding books all
they were old but like all of my wedding
magazines that I still had you know from
2019 when I got engaged because it was
all Long Engagement collected but um but
I brought all all of those over you know
we're both very witchy and so I even had
like a wedding like bra like a wedding
bridal book for like your zodiac sign so
uh we're both Sagittarius is so I
already had this stuff highlighted for
us I had all the things what's the
number one advice you would share with
Brides about planning a wedding about
planning
so fast a lot of dollar signs but just
make sure that like you love your
partner and it's all about you that day
so like be selfish be selfish don't
invite Uncle so and so just because Mom
is like buddy has to be there like
invite the people that you know and that
you love and just like really just think
about yourself and your partner it's
your day it's nobody else's hair goes by
really fast so you want to remember
everyone there and have those moments
with as many people as you can there
right yes exactly
this dress is beautiful thank you
we love in our life we I mean that what
does it mean to be here today everything
I I was very fortunate to grow up in New
York City which
when I was growing up was very loving
and and welcoming and accepting
community
so diverse I mean I I went to church uh
drag queens were in our choir I grew up
in the East Village so like
so it was normalized yeah so
um so I'm so happy to be here and
support all the work that the center
does
um because I just I feel I I've always
felt like I've just been embraced by the
community my entire life like
legitimately going to church with them
and they stand you I see it they let we
love you well do you see
if I want to get there did you really
yeah we're in the same class yeah when
she made it out to drag race were you
just like oh my God like I know who that
is so I knew her by a different name and
I didn't know that she was doing that
throughout High School
never told me
I would have gone to those shows or gone
to a show with her did not know
um but but then I saw her on the show
and I was like
they look so familiar how do I know that
it was like I'm from New York City I
went to performing arts school I was
like no there's absolutely no way and
we're still friends on Facebook from
high school so I went on it and I saw it
I was like no are you are you
kidding me so yeah huge star now that's
so awesome it's so amazing now Summer's
upon us and people want to know any
discussions about returning to love
Island USA possible
love that job and you were good at it
thank you thank you
I love I love those kids so much and um
I just I just saw myself saying I love
those kids looking at as if I'm a 12
year old I understand the irony that's
fine we're all kids at heart we're never
all kids we're all kids
um I I loved it so much and I think the
next season is gonna be fun it yeah yeah
foreign